e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment êtes vous devenu cambrioleurs ça
commence quand j'étais jeune déjà mes
vieux c'est pas le pognon il sert à pied
comme des poux alors les bretons doivent
être maintenant près d'hérisson alors si
je voulais quelque chose il fallait que
je le faut
l'histoire les gâteaux voulait jouer
n'importe quoi et avant d'y résister
beaucoup moins méfiants et grands
magasins comme lassana on n'a pas quoi
même la boulangerie doit d'être vieux
dire n importe quoi ils s'en rendent pas
compte bon ça va continuer comme ça
jusqu'à
je suis incertain là je crois jusqu'à
face à continuer tout le temps comment
ça se passait chez vous j'ai mes vieux
bas c'était pas la joie voilà mes vieux
je suis en france à un monstre engins
étaient portés aux nues mais moi la
veille à l'africaine et quand elle m'a
craché sur est alors c'est un peu par
bouard quoi je me suis rendue quand je
me suis rendu compte avec les années tu
vois que c'était différent et c'est
entre mon frangin mais moi je suis tout
mettre dans la merde mais avec vos
parents vous vous faisiez quoi bah je
sais pas allez viens avec mon vieux on
est fauché les chemins de fer les
traverses de chemin de fer dans la
courbe ailleurs
le ciment charbon de la ferrari tout ça
ça me plaisait lui reste à gauche ça
vous plaît ça me plaît c'est un peu
comme jean lavaud voleur mais pour de
vrai je me rendais pas compte étaient
tous morts ping mais ça vous êtes
toujours plus oui ça m'a toujours plu
maintenant ça me plaît moins bien sûr je
vous jean lamoureux la 54 ans ça
m'intéresse plus
[Musique]
aux premiers ennuis ont commencé après
la guerre habatjou et surtout vos
ampoules en taule j'ai fait trois ans
j'ai gagné six mois
je suis sorti donc au bout de deux ans
et demi mon futur aviation a pris mon
jeu c'est évident j'étais mis des
troubles dimanche
rien qu'au régulier et quand je le redis
je dis bon j'ai perdu deux ans et demi
de ma vie au plaqueur il faut qu'ils me
les paye je prendrai ma revanche en fait
en revanche en revanche si grange de
quad bas sur la société les gens
récupèrent ces années perdues des années
perdues au placard vous avez perdu au
plaqueur les récupérer en continuant d
récupère en continuant en prenant 10 ou
parce que le rêve de tout mal phrase
saisonnière bourgeois une bonne petite
vie tranquille
et comment choisissez-vous vos cours vos
cibles
bas on essaye de se poser sur un truc tu
iras du fric on peut pas savoir
exactement on n'a pas commencé prochain
ouvriers donc on va casser c'est pas par
sentiment parce qu'il est le premier à
nous courir au cul ce conte un cas si ça
ne me regarderait et c'est pas de sou
ailleurs et donc vous considérez
l'ouvrier comme c'est notre ennemi on va
ça c'est cette fois bon par exemple en
laisse car il vient de voler un si
jamais il y en a un qui gueule arrêté
lin qui c'est qui paye choro q c'est pas
un ingénieur c'est pas un avocat c'est
pas un toubib sais pas ainsi quand même
si hier nom qui veut dire ne pas risquer
dans la pauvreté des impôts pour payer
des frais tous ces connards là qu'ils
sont le premier à voleurs patrons les
fossés des clous davis c'est normal type
ya une bricole à faire chez lui s'il a
besoin vis à l'atelier va parler vous
achetez ce serait bien qu'on met le 1er
mai courir au cul s'il a joué les héros
qui cite une panne bulgares étaient
appelés pour lui
au début vous n'avez jamais pensé faire
autre chose non
pourquoi par exemple un travail
au
jeu rien [ __ ] vous n'avez jamais
travaillé si je travaille et si ce
travail et je travaillais 9 me contre 8
mois la fabrique de drague mi mollet sur
les cuisines à gaz un mois chez citroën
me jean fabbri
[Musique]
donc votre métier ses cambrioleurs oui
enfin si on peut appeler ça un métier
mais les gens sont devenus tellement
méfiants un cas notre époque que leur
faucher leur fric c'est plus un métier
stoner
[Rires]
comment et pourquoi
oui parce que déjà les souliers a plus
il y en a plus maintenant les banques ça
poussent comme des champignons vénéneux
les gens du carnet de chèques partout la
caisse d'epargne ici et ça semblait dire
ou de sûreté est aujourd'hui dans tous
les coins des des papes plain d'aidé au
mitan des signaux d'alarmé
et puis alors sans oublier les lézards
qui abusent en sorte qu'ils aient pour
un oui pour un non il coûtait ce qu'on
fait ça par facile mais quel genre de
coup est-ce que vous montez à bord des
petits cambriolages quoi un commerçant
n'importe comment et comme elle est la
sagesse des anciens un
mercure dieu des voleurs et des
marchands sont pas fous les met dans le
même sac
dans son choix d'un confrère déjà une
revanche un peu sur la société sept prix
puis ça pousse peut-être un mois deux
mois peut-être huit jours dans les
foires les français de faire la valise
voilà alors là ça court mais toujours
cet esprit de revanche pourquoi aide
revanche la wii sport parce que
ils m'ont pris une partie de ma vie
alors on prend une bonne partie 1,54 en
mangerait pas c'est parce que tu rentres
ou platière un bon maintenant maintenant
je suis commencé à baisser pavillon
parce que j'en peux plus j'ai trop vieux
mais quand j'étais jeune j'ai produit x
qui me paye sapho qui me plaît qui
savent où je vais j'ai passé pas mal
d'années ma vie en prison mais il faut
que je réussisse à me ramasser des sous
mais vous parlez comme si dès le départ
c'était la société qui était coupable
vous aviez la punir alors je veux pas la
punir leur disons qu'ils ne l'aiment pas
je n'aime pas parce que je sais mais bon
c'est normal ce sont mes ennemis
société il n'aime pas les voleurs ils
ont raison la côte est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
mais pourquoi considérez vous la société
comme votre ennemi parce que c'était
sale con j'ai vu tant de choses il
autant de choses qui se passaient en
présentons quelques complicités
d'associer technique votre société mon
propos spécialement à toile a tous je
vois des trucs par exemple il ya un môme
qui es cannet des maures et tout frais
dans un sac de leur en but par
l'affermir dérape yacco que plongeur de
l'autisme enfin adopté six ans public et
bien le journal il mettait au le drame
de la bêtise qu'on sait ça l'était en
provisoire ça du peut s'arranger aux
assises dont la plupart c'est encore des
blues il n'y a pas ça les jurés c'est
des bons pecqueur alors ils en ont rien
à [ __ ] d'un môme qui crèvent sur
toutes ces maisons mais faut voir là
dedans qu'il ya passé par il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas quelques irresponsables
il ya la famille avec
sa lampe ou de mes hôtes il voyait bien
qu'ils crever la dalle logiquement ces
mots il ya un toubib d'assistance
publique qui doit s'occuper de ce môme
il veut les contrôler et de danse à voir
c'est un squelette ambulant et une
assistante sociale qui devait suivre ça
devait repartir et qu'une douzaine de
tout ça c'est des ordures ça mérite pas
de vivre ont tous un moment que les
mérite pas de rio je suis pas un saint
mais des [ __ ] comme ça c'est nettoyer
et si la société l'espère c'est une
société d'enculés en une société comme
ça j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de bons faire
partie vous dites que vous n'avez
personne et que vous n'aurez jamais
personne vivant
parce que j'ai toujours été habitué mais
mettant morpion les deux seuls patients
je me vois pas avec une gonzesse je sais
pas pourquoi mais je suis sur mes filles
et des femmes je sais pas si c'est la
cause de ma vieille 1 que c'était la
haine entre deux une guerre froide que
l'on gère près jamais confiance à une
baisse du ratio prêts confiance à
personne un châle nourrit ne les fera
pas
vous n'êtes personnes autour de vous à
qui me fait confiance non à confiance à
fond non
et des amis vous en avais tes copains me
joly
mais vous n'avez jamais ressenti un
sentiment quelconque pour une personne
en cherchant bien la haine plutôt
des gens de tout le monde oh oui oui
plus sable petit à petit c'est venu
petit à petit après je vais demander
remontés à bloc je le suis toujours du
reste c'est pas moi par exemple je vois
bon qu'un jouet à mauzac îliens l'avion
qui se casse la gueule on voit ça sur le
journal les gens à regarder regarde ça
ces pauvres gens qui sont mal jsk foot
oui vous êtes enterré vivant en afrique
qui crève d'ailleurs c'est pas compliqué
à zurich une catastrophe tout va si ça
se produit en france je me frotte les
mains bravo c'est compris que ça me
rapporte rien ses bras portent pas un
sou mais je suis content ainsi qu'un
salon fait du mal et donc le malheur des
autres ces bandes et a fait des allées
comment pourquoi parce que gilles ange1
de 29 ans plaqueur faut comprendre
et en prison vous avez tenté de vous
évader bien sûr de file donc se faire la
valise alors j'ai essayé bon jouer à
reims je me suis cassé la gueule de deux
mètres en voulant fuir les riches des
coupes à un barreau j'ai mis un écriteau
sur le sur le guichet chambre à louer et
puis c'est pas j'ai lâché les draps
assez incroyable coup comme ça on dirait
qu'ils doivent on entre en mur j'ai
senti que j'avais tout la saison passée
est à dire je n'ai fait du béton blanc
la colonne le poignet le talon
et puis je bête sur d'autres j'essayais
dans l'est pour voir si l'intrus dans
les hôpitaux où j'ai coupé il manque 5
orteils trop bien un billet d'entrée
bien sûr avec un couteau et puis une
balayette portal faire pour aller dans
l'hôpital civil vers 6 et 20 trous pour
s'arracher parce qu'il s'arrache et des
tôles c'est pas facile il manque le riz
cuit la gauche et des pareils
l'auriculaire je les coupe en quatre
fois les orteils et je dois voir bon il
manque 50 ha il devrait à peu près 15
coupe j'ai aussi percé le poumon j'ai
donc ouvert j'aime été un fil de fer
entre deux entre deux côtes où j'étais
5e s'arrangeant pour la première fois
j'avais fait une piqûre au centre jean
s'il se sent plus pourri qu'on a sur soi
ce avec une gomme vaincu le moenner
rappelle chuté à la longue c'est peu de
temps à monter des combats abri remontée
des combis des bandes qui est temps de
faire la valise bien sur la fin mais je
suis sorti bêtement par la lune où j'ai
pas eu de poste à clermont-ferrand
j'm'en un fil de fer et bancs de touche
calcul malmont couche tombée d'une côte
j'ai bien senti que je perds c'est gagne
quelque chose en plus c'était le
diaphragme et ça glissait sur le voyage
ans pour les crapules mais mon peuple si
mon père l'a besançon j'en fais les
valises montferrand je me refais la
balise mais manque de prise par ces
appareils ne peuvent demeurer les
normands they kiss cool en italie on
s'arrache mais c'est pourri en oeuvre
olalala départ les taux de la crds
palier qui secoue et quelle est votre
situation aujourd'hui par rapport à la
justice ben maintenant genre ne put rien
je dormirai
[Musique]
m
la solitude vous en souffrez
j'ai toujours été seul c'est une
question d'habitude mais enfin des fois
oui je vois ça pèse un peu enfin la
banque comme angélique
mais ça je suis bien tenir les animaux
les chiens se courent pas trop après ils
m'ont tellement fait perdre 2 càs de
cambriolages ils faisaient leur métier
en aboyant ma famille mon péché sur 2000
mais à quel moment est ce que vous
sentez vraiment la solitude
bah tiens par exemple un truc qui m'a
frappé
c'était je réussir quatre mois de
contraintes je suis sortie au bout de
deux mois 18 jours j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi enfin asseoir le dernier panier
qui ramène les dossiers allez hop alors
bon je me suis retrouvé donc certes en
avait que quelques là ce qui a été
sortie soit équité soit qu'ils avaient
fait dépasser leur peine quand ils sont
passés au tribunal ce jour là soit les
liberté provisoire parce que ça ça
arrive par le dernier panier du palais
de justice
c'était la santé à l'époque moi je vous
retrouve et on s'est retrouvés chaud
pour moi 5 6 2 or et c'est marrant tout
le monde y avait quelqu'un qui les
attendait pas de famille ou n'importe
quoi alors toc toc 520 s'embrasser et
tout ça ça pourrait pas leur ils sont
tous partis puis moi je suis ça m'a
frappée parce qu'ils sont restés tout
seul comme un con à vous et moi qu'est
ce que je suis de penser qu'ils veulent
a crevé personnes qui sont vécues
président français aussi bien mais enfin
j'ai pensé c'est gilles sont peut-être
trompés louis gill sont peut-être
trompés après tout deux mois 18 jours
mais sa sortie avant je réponds à franck
il y en a qui viennent de reprendre à
toi là enfin ça m'avait fait drôle de
savoir où va s'arrêter la sphère de la
diminution aussi bien comme ça pourquoi
c'est bien
parce que le jour j à crever c'est
terminé il peut faire du poteau fait
avec moi ces îles volantes j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] de maccarthysme regret éternel
et un pommeau soir tout ça c'est du
cinéma
[Musique]